hello everybody
i am father speaking to you from the
blue headquarters in geneva
and welcoming you to our global covet 19
press conference today monday
16 november present in the room
is the w2 director general dr tedros
in the room also dr mike ryan executive
director health emergencies
dr
director general access to medicine and
health products
dr ed kelly director of integrated
health services
as usual we have simultaneous
interpretation in
six u.n official languages plus
portuguese
and hinduism now without further ado
i will hand over to dr teddles for his
opening remark
dr tedros you have the flow thank you
thank you fedele
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
this is not the time for complacency
while we continue to receive encouraging
news about covet 19 vaccines
and remain cautiously optimistic about
the potential
for new tools to start to arrive in the
coming
months right now we're extremely
concerned
by the surging cases we're seeing in
some countries
particularly in europe and the americas
health workers and health systems are
being pushed
to the breaking point who has issued
guidance and tools to increase capacity
for the medical and public health
workforce
and supplies and facilities to manage
coveted 19 patients at present
double jo has 150 emergency medical
teams
assisting countries in the planning and
implementation of their emergency
responses
who and partners are working with
governments and health leaders
to ensure that there is cover for health
workers
that are sick that there are
enough beds for kobe 19 patients and for
essential
services to continue safely
that there are enough masks gloves and
other protective equipment
that governments have access to enough
tests
therapeutics and supplies to cope with
demand now and that systems
will be ready when safe and effective
vaccines
are rolled out health workers on the
front lines
have been straight for months they're
exhausted
we must do all we can to protect them
especially during this period
when the virus is spiking and patients
are feeling hospital beds
in this moment when some governments
have put all of society restrictions in
place
there is once again another window of
time
to strengthen key systems we have seen
that
those countries which invested in case
finding
care and isolation cluster
investigations
adequate testing with rapid results
contact pressing
and supported quarantine are facing
much less
and contract contact tracing are part of
the
bedrock of a successful public response
these actions help prevent individual
cases from becoming clusters
and clusters turning into community
transmission
during recent ebola outbreaks the
democratic republic of the congo
and dubli to have invested in people and
trained up
a sizable number of contact tracers
who work closely with local leaders
and communities and in just two days
in part down to active case finding and
contract racism
they will be able i hope to call an end
to the most recent ebola outbreak
as countries take extreme measures to
curb the rapid spread
of kobe 19. now is the time
to invest in the systems that will
prevent further
waves of the virus invest
in a well-trained and protected public
health workforce so that you have
enough contact treasures in place and
ensure that those who are sick can
isolate away from others
and contacts are identified notified
which can attack every system in the
body
those countries that are letting the
virus run unchecked
are playing with fire first
there will be further needless and
suffering
second as we featured two weeks ago
in a press conference we're seeing a
significant number of people
experiencing
long-term effects of the virus sir
health workers in particular are facing
extreme mental health pressure and cases
are
severely burdening our systems in too
many countries health workers went into
medicine
to save lives as you know we must avoid
putting them into situations where they
have to make impossible choices
about who gets care and who does it
we need to do everything we can to
support health workers
keep schools open protect the
vulnerability
and safeguarding the economy
from calling up students volunteers and
even national guards
to support the health response in times
of crisis
to putting strict measures in place that
allow pressure to be removed
from the health system there is no
excuse for inaction my message is very
clear
act fast act now act indecisively
attitude to the virus not using the full
range of
tools available leads to death
suffering and hurts livelihoods and
economies
it's not a choice between lives
the quickest way to open up economies
is to defeat
[Music]
leaders came together at both the world
health assembly
and the paris peace forum
high on the agenda was the act
accelerator
and ensuring equitable access to new
rapid tests
therapeutics and kobe 19 vaccines
the european commission france
and the bill and melinda gates
foundation plays 360 million us
dollars the vaccines pillar
of the act accelerated
[Music]
to ensure that tools are rolled out
quickly across the world
so that we save lives stabilize
health systems and drive a truly global
recovery
another 4.2 billion s dollars is needed
urgently and a further 23.9 billion us
dollars
will be required in 2021
these countries spending trillions to
prop up economies
g20 leaders will meet this weekend
this is an opportunity for them to
commit financially
and politically to the act accelerator
and combat
so that together we can end this
pandemic
it's also a moment for us to strive
for the world we want this
cannot be business as usual
the time has come for a fundamental
shift towards
to reflect this last week i launched
a new current council on the economics
of health forum to be chaired by
the distinguished economist
to put universal health coverage at the
center of how we think about
value creation and economic growth
like the climate crisis inequality
and conflict cannot be tackled in silos
a new collective way forward is needed
to ensure that we deliver on the
promises
of the past and tackle this intertwined
challenges
together i thank you
thank you dr tedros for those remarks i
would like just to
add an information we have with us dr
sumiya suaminata chief scientist and dr
keith o'brien director immunization
vaccines and
biological remotely
now i would like to open the floor to
questions from members of the media i
remind you
that you need to raise your hand use the
raise your hand function
in order to get in the queue to ask your
question
i will start with antonio brotto
from fa the spanish news agency antonio
can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
is
thank you antonio swaminathan
can you hear me
yes i can thank you for the question
there was an echo i can start and maybe
it can come in
the question i think was about the news
of the modena vaccine
yes exactly that it's quite encouraging
the we've just heard about the interim
results from
the press release from modena it's a
fairly detailed press release
and we know that uh in the interim
analyses
it appears that the vaccine is actually
has a protective efficacy of over 90
it's about 94 of course we need to wait
and see
what the final efficacy and the safety
profile
of this vaccine will be when the whole
data is analyzed after they reach
their uh primary end point
and also have enough follow-up of at
least two months
of half the trial participants
for the side effects and that will then
be submitted to the regulatory agencies
as far as the kovacs facility is
concerned
we're working very closely with gavi and
seppi the the facility has been
established
and the facility is discussing
with vaccine manufacturers from around
the world
we are open to procurement of vaccine
roses
there are criteria of course for the
procurement and there is an independent
prioritization group that's been set up
that will look
at the dossiers that will look at the
data that
manufacturers are submitting and then
there are the cost considerations
as well there's the affordability and
then there are practical considerations
like the need for cold storage
the number of doses of vaccine that will
be required
the ease of the number of doses that may
be
available early in 2021 so there will be
apart from efficacy and safety
other considerations that the facility
will
consider when making a decision on
whether or not to go ahead with a
contract
at this point there is um
we we cannot announce uh uh anything
further about which companies
there have uh there are negotiations
going on of course with several
uh at the moment and uh one very
encouraging thing is to see that at
least with the two mrna vaccine
results that we've heard pfizer and
moderna
that we seem to be achieving high
efficacy but there are many many
questions still remaining about the
duration of protection
the impact on severe disease the impact
on different sub-populations especially
the elderly
as well as the adverse events beyond a
certain period of time
so we also hope that the clinical trials
will continue to collect data because
that's really going to be important for
us
to know about in the long term and we're
looking forward to getting more results
in the coming weeks
from the other vaccine trials that are
that are currently
in progress
um thank you dr swaminathan
dr o'brien do you have something to add
thank you the only thing i would add to
that um really good explanation from dr
swaminathan is that the
delivery characteristics of vaccines are
also important
uh and um we will be looking really
carefully
at the the ease with which different
vaccines can be delivered and
and uh certainly about the number of
doses that are required these are
um this is a two dose vaccine um and
certainly any vaccine that can
can achieve a one dose vaccine is
certainly easier to deliver than a two
dose vaccine
and of course the cold chain
characteristics are also important so
information from the moderna vaccine
about its um requirements of both minus
20 and then refrigeration
for a period of week of what they're
indicating maybe a month period is
welcome news as well
thank you dr o'brien i would like now to
invite
bayern altook a nadulu news agency to
ask the next question
byram can you hear me hi father thank
you very much for giving me this
opportunity and
good evening everybody and
china seems to have recorded almost no
need
or very little case for a while i mean
for months
can we assume that chinese authorities
have
successfully contained the virus to
close
in on end and the pandemic if this is
the case
so what does the who attribute such
success
and what are the lessons learned from
the rest of the world
there are have also been unconfirmed
reports of chinese for being much higher
so what would you like to say about this
question thank you
thank you for the question um many
countries have actually
dealt with sometimes serious
epidemics within the wrong countries and
have found
the comprehensive means by which to
control the infection
test and trace contacts quarantine
contacts treat their sick
and keep the virus once they've had it
low keep the virus at a very low level
china is amongst those countries but
others like
korea singapore japan
new zealand now australia and others so
this has been a fight that many
countries have taken
to the virus i think what's common in
their approaches
while the approaches have been very
different and they're in very different
cultural settings what has been common
in their approach is really a relentless
focus
on doing it all a relentless focus on uh
mobilizing community action like in
thailand with community-based
surveillance and response
a relentless focus on testing tracing
and quarantine
as you saw australia really fight back
against a very difficult
epidemic in in melbourne and victoria
the people of victoria sacrificed 101
days i think in
in virtual lockdown with uh ramping up
of surveillance and has
they've turned the corner there
significantly so from
from that perspective i think what we
can see uh
between countries is that capacity both
to chase the virus take the fight to the
virus
protect vulnerable groups keep the
health system ticking over
and when you get to that low level
following through with very aggressive
measures when cases and clusters
occur very good cluster investigation
like we've seen in places
like japan both prospective contact
tracing and retrospective investigation
of cases to find out where whether they
were part of clusters
so much of that is the stuff we've been
saying for months and months
a comprehensive strategy aimed at
sorry controlling the virus aimed at
protecting the vulnerable
aimed at saving lives in with regard to
your
the other part of your question with
regard to
current incidents in countries
i think many countries have very very
low numbers of cases
there's always the risk of importation
of cases or undetected cases
in any country we have no evidence right
now
that the situation in china is anything
other than
extremely low levels of the virus
with a very aggressive response to any
um
up surges that you've seen again with
much of the mass testing that's going on
and mass testing is not something that's
accessible to all countries that takes a
huge amount of resources to do
and for many countries that's not a
feasible or even advisable option but in
the situations where it has been done
very few cases have actually been picked
up as part of that mass testing
if there were a large number of
undetected cases
in the context of local transmission one
would expect
to find cases through that process so no
i we don't believe at this point
that there's any evidence that points to
a significant
problem uh in in china
maria yeah just to highlight the the
part of the
the question of what can we learn from
others i think that's exactly the right
question we need to be asking and
constantly asking
because there's so much that we're
learning from each other as mike has
pointed out this
is a comprehensive set of measures that
china that japan that australia that's
so many countries that germany that
so many countries have been using right
now and i think some of the things that
stand
out um is the doing it all making sure
that there's a comprehensive aggressive
approach
in case finding but using the system
that's also in place
to find cases that may be picked up in
the community
so using your influenza surveillance
system or your respiratory disease
surveillance system that exists in
country
to also test a subset of those for covet
19
are incredibly helpful to see you if you
might be missing chains of transmission
and some of the things that work you've
heard us say many times before
arguably some of the most important
things to do is to be able to isolate
cases really isolate those cases in a
medical facility if possible
in a community center that is
specifically catered for coded patients
depending on the severity of their
systems or if they need to be cared for
at home
making sure that they're isolated from
other family members
this is difficult to do in
multi-generational homes or homes that
have a lot of different people
but having a known case in the home they
need to be isolated from their loved
ones
and that will really help break those
chains of transmission the other thing
is supported
quarantine so finding the contacts of
the known cases
and putting these individuals safely
securely
supported in a quarantined facility or
again if they need to be quarantined at
home
away from others this is what breaks
chains of transmission
um and in countries the last thing just
to highlight
one of the things we repeatedly see
in countries is when you have a
supported
enabled empowered community to carry out
individual level measures where they
know where i know what
i need to do what does my family need to
do what does my community need to do
all of that contributes to reducing the
spread
and that is something we we cannot
emphasize enough
because right now we need everyone
everyone everywhere
to really be doing what they can to
support um to make sure that they don't
get infected themselves
and to make sure that they don't pass
the virus to someone else should they
either be infected or exposed
um and so these are things that we need
to continue to focus on and we will
continue to
put these messages out day in and day
out
thank you i would like now to invite
grenina van gaal
to ask the next question ganila can you
hear me
yes i can hear you can you hear me yeah
very well go ahead please
uh thanks marilyn thank you for taking
my question it concerns sweden
uh um sweetness had a very different
strategy from the rest of the world
until now until today actually when the
government has introduced very very
tough
restrictions and it's basically the end
or what's called the swedish
strategy um i'd like to hear what you
think about this is this
radical shift is it a sign of a
misunderstanding
or misjudgment or what has been needed
really to stop the virus
and how useful can it be in this
situation with a surge of cases
to recommend the use of face masks in
sweden
which is basically the only country um
not recommending face masks thank you
i think all countries have had to adapt
to the realities of this wave of
transmission of the virus
i think it was uh quite clear in the in
the first months of the
the spread of this disease the violet
had a major impact
the vast majority of people still remain
susceptible to the virus
in most cases more than 90 percent
as the virus has spread again
particularly in the european region
and as people have
you know suffered that fatigue of
maintaining physical distance
wearing mass hand washing not attending
crowds and gatherings
it is difficult it's difficult for for
all to maintain
discipline in that self-managed
discipline in that
the the the swedish authorities uh had
engaged and had
i believe very high levels of compliance
with their original measures
back in the spring and that social
contract that exists in sweden the fact
that
the majority i think over 50 percent of
households in sweden are single-person
households
they did see issues in long-term care
facilities among some immigrant
populations who live in
multi-generational homes
so it wasn't without its difficulties i
think the
this time around sweden has begun to
implement and ask its population to do
even more
in terms of behavioral behavioral
adaptation and that is added into that
some mandated measures uh who's advice
uh regarding mass wearing i i think is
is is quite clear
masks work mass work in particular
environments where you can't maintain
physical distance
where you're in a crowded setting we
would like people to look at all aspects
of how you protect yourself
to look at your your risk score in a
sense on a weekly basis you need to look
at all of the activities
in terms of the locations the durations
and the intensity
of the contact you're going to have with
people in those situations
there are many situations where wearing
a mask
is a very good addition to all of the
other measures maintaining physical
distance and
and washing hands avoiding crowded
places
and in particular linking the the hand
sanitization and hand washing to mask
use as well it's really important that
people wear
masks properly use the right kind of
masks but also wear masks
properly fitted on their face and not
under their nose and also
take care that when you're applying the
mask and taking off the mask you're
using your hands
and therefore that should always be done
with the proper regard for
for sanitization so we would have we
would advise all countries
in situations of widespread community
transmission to consider the utilization
of mass
in those specific contexts where
transmission risk
is high i'll pass to maria for the
specifics on that but again with regard
it's it's easy in all of these
situations countries are on a journey
and countries are trying to use the data
as best they can to protect their
populations
these decisions are made in good faith
they are evidence-based and they
represent the
considered view of people who advise on
on policy adjusting and shifting and
changing those policies
is not a weakness that's a strength it
takes courage sometimes to to move away
from a path
and recognize that you have to add
additional measures that that's not a
failure that that's a sign that the
system is capable of listening
adapting and adjusting to new realities
that you didn't expect to be the case
so this is not a time i believe for
recrimination this is a time for
solidarity
of moving forward together finding the
right combination of measures that works
and then implementing it in a consistent
and fair fashion with the least
recrimination possible maintaining unity
if at all possible between all sectors
of society and government
maria
i think okay thank you dr
ryan um i would like now to invite
uh refi jeremy lunch from radio france
international to ask the next
the next question jeremy uh can you hear
me
yes i can hear you fellow can you hear
me yeah very well go ahead please
thanks um a question
i would like to know what is the
dominant feeling right now
at who are you more amazed
by the results of than either and the
likes
are you more worried that those vaccines
if proven effective will only be
available
in rich countries thanks
merci jeremy dr simao
let me start and and then dr sumiya can
can complement of course we are very
happy to hear
positive results but there are many
vaccine candidates coming up with
results before the end of this year and
beginning of next year
and some will be easier to implement at
country level and some will be
more challenging but overall we we
see the the landscape as very very
promising so far and the fact that we
have already two vaccine candidates that
are showing interim results at 90
ninety four point eight five uh efficacy
results
it's it's quite quite encouraging of
course as i mentioned there
are challenges in the implementation but
we are also
aiming with through the kovacs facility
in ensuring that countries will have a
chance to
opportunity to to have access to the
vaccines they prefer
in due time and that we don't have a
long lagging period
between these vaccines rich in
developing countries
and developed countries somehow i don't
know if you want to compliment
dr swaminathan i think
and we remain optimistic and we would
like to work with all
manufacturers and developers
with the kovacs facility to ensure that
we have
the widest possible um
selection of candidates available
because some candidates will
will suit more in certain situations
perhaps in certain subgroups like
elderly
some will have different storage
conditions uh and so on so it would be
good to really have a portfolio
of products to so that countries can
also have
some choice in the matter but i think
we're looking at
at least the first half of next year as
being
a period of very very limited closes
supplies are going to be limited um
there are bilateral deals that many of
the companies have done
so many of the doses have already been
booked by some countries
we are hoping that there will be enough
in the facility so that the
amc countries the 92 countries the amc
group will also get access to these
doses
at the same time um but right now
it's it's just a question of planning
week by week and day by day
but our goal is to ensure that
the highest risk people in all countries
dr tedros mentioned the health workers
were under tremendous strain
and were also being disproportionately
affected by this pandemic
we want to make sure that these
front-line workers
regardless of which country they're in
are protected
and that's our goal and we're trying to
work with all countries
um to see that that this happens but
this again as dr ted ross had said many
times
this requires global solidarity to
really
ensure that we achieve the goal of
equitable access
dr ryan please yeah i think it's good
for us too to reflect on
on the amazing journey that
we've all been on in terms of uh global
science
and and to reflect on the fact that
before this pandemic started
as part of the research and development
blueprint we had
target product profiles for coronavirus
vaccines for disease x
for therapeutics and the world and many
scientists have come together
to agree on what we would need to be
doing really quickly in the face of a
pandemic
that transformed
in february within a few days of the
the doctor dr tedwas declaring the
highest level of global alert
into a research and development role map
which was the result of hundreds of
scientists coming together
under the leadership of people like
sumiya and marie angela maria
and so many others in the rnd who
support the r d blueprint
that roadmap then was used as a
blueprint to bring together technical
partners dr tedros has been working
at the political level on this issue
since march since
april talking to global leaders going
way way back trying to build an alliance
and a coalition between multilateral
organizations
and powerful member states to create the
momentum that could drive
this forward but we are at that moment
of great hope but we need to hope with
attitude
we need to hope with determination with
planning with investment with financing
with implementation with readiness the
issues that kate mentioned
about getting countries ready to be able
to deliver this vaccine to those who
will benefit from it
and ensuring that's done with equity so
yes it is a moment of
of great hope and it is a moment that
demonstrates what
human civilization and what science can
deliver
when when it works across ideological uh
and gov
and country boundaries when it works to
towards a common good
a common goal a global good and when we
see that happening we should take hope
from that
science solidarity and solutions as ted
russ has said
almost every day at this press
conference and he says that every day to
us
that's what we have to focus on and i
think we should have hope we should have
realistic hope that we're not there yet
and uh a testament to
to to everyone and kovacs and everyone
in the r d blueprint everybody
uh who supports the work that mary
angelo is doing leading
on allocation and equitable allocation
we're not there yet but
i certainly would strike a note of hope
in this regard
thank you all i think dr ed kelly would
like to add something
just really briefly on mike's point that
we're not there yet but we're getting
there i mean i think
these points that we've raised earlier
about the measures that need to be taken
continue to take now and will
be needed even after the vaccine is
introduced last week we had
60 000 deaths we had four million new
cases we'll have more of those weeks
before the vaccine is out there
and i think we i'm sure my partner kate
would mention what also sumiya and
mariangela mention it's
uh not vaccines that save people it's
vaccinations that will actually save
people so the delivery function and the
work on the act accelerator
is an important piece of that we have
spent recently
work over the past two weeks plus to
really integrate the work
of the vaccines pillar of the act
accelerator with the health systems
strengthening work that's there working
with the act accelerator partners
as well as with the world bank and
really focusing on
ramping up delivery in a hundred
countries over uh
the next hundred days to really look at
how we can accelerate readiness and i
think that piece is going to be key
thank you um i would like also to ask dr
kate o'brien
who has something to add dr o'brien
i really want to emphasize um the you
know great excitement there is uh not
only at who but i'm sure around the
world
the results that are coming out now from
two phase three clinical
efficacy trials the part i really want
to emphasize is
we have plenty of vaccines that are
life-saving vaccines
measles is an example of that a highly
efficacious vaccine
over 95 percent efficacy and yet we
still have measles outbreaks and so the
importance of
having achieved uh if you know if
obviously the data need to be reviewed
by regulators and a full
a full analysis of of the data needs to
be taken and these trials need to be
completed as
sumiya has emphasized but this is um
there was a
really nice analogy recently about
getting to vaccine efficacy is like
building base camp
at everest but the climb to the peak is
really about delivering the vaccines
and and this cannot be over emphasized
that the people who need to receive
these vaccines
um are the ones who um really are the
are the focus now um as we as we start
to see that with that we have vaccines
that that may in fact really um have
very strong efficacy so the work is
really beginning
in in every country around the world
of exactly how are we going to
manage in every country to immunize
health workers
um we don't have strong programs for
immunization of adults in many many
countries around the world so this is
really going to have to lean on the
programs for immunization that we have
in every country around the world
but they have largely focused on infants
children and adolescents
so there's an enormous amount of work to
do and
and and resources that will be needed to
actually deliver the vaccines
to everybody who needs these vaccines uh
should they
in fact um come forward as as some of
these press releases indicate um they
should
thank you all i would like to give the
floor to tomorrow from
kyodo tomo can you hear me
yes can you hear me very well go ahead
please
thank you uh dr tedros uh
congratulations that you're uh back in
the uh
actual podium not the virtual on this
press conference
so you have finally tested negative on
the
coronavirus and uh another question if i
made to uh dr van kerkov
uh we see the reports of associated
press that there's a cluster of
infections going on in the ratio uh
could you clarify about how many cases
in
which headquarters and how serious the
situation is thank you
i will uh thank you tomo for the for the
question it's nice to
to hear your voice again um so yes we
we are as you know um as all uh
workplaces we are following
um infections and we're monitoring the
health of all of
all of our staff all over the world uh
we have had cases that have been
uh staff members um and not yes i did
also see the ap story um there have been
65 cases associated with
hq staff headquarters staff not all of
which have been on the premises
um there have been 36 those 65 are from
the start of the pandemic
so let us be very clear on that and
clearly
the ap is reporting on an email that was
sent
to staff about that so those are 65
cases reported since the beginning of
the year um
36 have been uh have had access to the
premises who have been on the premises
as i'm sure you know we've reduced
greatly reduced our staff
um in the building we're working in
these different types of phases
depending on the epidemiologic situation
in the areas that are around us as most
workplaces are doing
and we have had some cases that have
been associated with the premises
we do have some cases in the last week
that are linked together we don't know
if they're an actual cluster
so what we do is when we have any cases
uh is we first
make sure that they have access to a
test make sure that they have access to
appropriate care
all are doing well all have mild disease
um or asymptomatic um and
we are trapped tracing back and we're
also tracing forward
so what we do is we carry out contact
tracing to see who they came in contact
with
to see if there are any further onward
transmission as most countries are doing
but we also look back to see what did
they do in the previous 14 days for
example
and so we do have cases that are linked
within a team
but there are possible ways in which
they were infected outside of the
premises
so we're still doing the epidemiologic
investigation with that with these
individuals
but they are all doing well and just for
your information
we have initiated a number of practices
in the building
again as all workplaces have with our
physical distancing
with the use of masks when we can't
physical distance making sure our
ventilation is appropriate
making sure that we reduce the footprint
on the campus we limit
our in-person meetings we have utilized
a lot of the different online platforms
to have our meeting so that we continue
to do the work that we do we have tape
on the floor that help us
you know where it's appropriate to sit
to make sure that we keep our spacing
so we are constantly looking at the
measures that we have in place
we adjust them as necessary and we will
continue to do so
so thank you very much for the question
and the concern for our staff
um yeah i think it's also important
to clarify that maria
myself ted ross or anyone
at this table we don't control the
contact tracing or other processes
in-house we don't get to say who stays
or who goes dr federos
has stayed home not because i told him
or he told himself
because our contact tracing teams made
that decision
we have a special working group made up
of key experts around the house they
meet they decide
they investigate they apply the
principles
of our standard operating procedures for
managing cases in-house
there's there's no policy discussion of
someone should come in or should not
come in
that is purely made on the basis of our
sops and and of science
and and that has has worked uh
very well and served us well over the
last over the last
nine ten months we also are able to
increase and decrease the number of
staff on site we're able to increase and
decrease the levels
of restriction which are commensurate
with the
local epidemiology and i can remind you
that the cantons of wall
and cantons of geneva that surround us
have some of the most intense
transmission in the world right now
so our staff are out there living in
communities to my knowledge the
the cluster being investigated is the
first evidence of
potential transmission on the
site of who but we can't completely
protect ourselves
from our own as you many out there from
your own
social and other engagements with family
and school and so many other things we
all
we are human beings and we live within a
society and we're not entirely within
a cocoon here um and i'll be glad to
confirm this as maria said i was joking
with
ed beforehand that we've significantly
replaced the red tape with the yellow
tape
here at the w.h.o
sorry i need to come back in because i'm
being asked to clarify so when i said
that there were 36 cases uh associated
with the premises that's since the
beginning of the pandemic
there have been five cases uh in testing
positive in the last week
so we just want to clarify uh that point
but also to say as mike said we're
normal human beings we do we do our
grocery shopping we do
our we have to take our kids to school
we are living in an area right now that
has
very high incidence surrounding us and
so we
as individuals also need to take into
account the measures to keep ourselves
safe
what we recommend to you and what you
hear us saying every single day is what
we say to our own staff
to our loved ones um but just to clarify
that it's this it's been 65 cases
associated with
um hq since the beginning of the
pandemic 36 of which have had
access to the premises and only five in
the last week
could i just further clarify because we
use the word
associate there to all those amateur
epidemiologists out there
that does not mean that transmission
occurred on these premises
uh those individuals were people who
were designated
as working on site and therefore they
were
left home to self-isolate and their
contacts traced outside so just
when we use the word associated i'm sure
we'll get a lot of
feedback the the this last cluster under
investigation to our knowledge is the
only
evidence of our potential transmission
on
this campus over the last 10 months
thank you thank you both i would like
now to call on
elena gordon from the word gbh
to ask the next question elena can you
hear me
can you unmute yourself please elena yes
can you hear me
yes very well go ahead please um so my
question
and i hope that everybody is doing well
was related to this associated press
um outbreak or not outbreak but cases
that have been reported recently within
the w.h.o
and i wanted to follow up i guess on
that and ask um it was reported that a
member of the leadership team
had also been tested positive and i
wonder if you had more details
about that and i hope that that person
is doing well
so again there's no outbreak at
hq here headquarters in geneva
what we are doing is we are following
actively monitoring the health
and safety of all of our staff members
every day we fill in a questionnaire
that asks how we're doing that takes our
temperature
where we are working and gives our
contact information
if anyone fits a suspected case
definition
they are followed up and they are tested
and we make sure that people get the
appropriate care that they need we have
been doing this since
day one we have taken a number of steps
to make sure that we reduce
our opportunities for infection we
reduce the opportunities for
any potential transmission in the
building and elsewhere
so this is something that we are we are
we take very seriously as all
workplaces do um and so the the
um those who test positive is
confidential
as is confidential in other locations as
well
um but the people who had tested
positive in the last week are doing well
they are being followed up um they are
resting comfortably at home
we're checking in on them every day and
making sure that they have what they
need and if they need any any support
then we will drop off care packages if
necessary
and we are also making sure that those
who are contacts have been identified
and are also being supported in
quarantine
so that is something that we will
continue to do until this pandemic ends
thank you dr kelly and just to add to
that i mean since it's a question about
leadership team i think
it's also important to add last week we
just
completed the first fully digital
world health assembly with all of our
leadership participating
dr tedros obviously at a distance so as
someone who's been here
with the team since the beginning of the
outbreak
i can tell you as mike says the amount
of uh
yellow tape telling you which way to go
up the quarter which way to come down
the quarter
where you can sit where you can't sit
the amount of space in between the
amount of space shut down
in terms of any eating establishments
the amount of cleaning that is happening
in all of the offices
is exponential and has gone up during
the time that we've been here
we've also looked as at an opportunity
to really change the way who does its
business how it engages with countries
how it engages with senior leadership
and how our leadership engages with them
so i think those are also opportunities
thank you um the next question is for
agnes pedreiro from agents franchise
can you hear me yes hello i can hear you
hi everybody thank you for taking my my
question uh it's just a follow-up
of one question that was asked before
from
my colleague it was on the
just to know if dr tedros has been
tested negative to come back to uh
to to the headquarters thank you maybe i
didn't listen the answer but sorry
thank you
thank you um first of all glad to be
back
and second working from home is very
tough
of course i work on
weekends and evenings
even before kobe during kovid
but when you do it during the working
days working
hours from home it's very very difficult
especially coordinating
[Music]
running an assembly while under
quarantine is
is very very tough as you can see and
the most busiest two weeks
while i was under quarantine because of
the assembly
but at the same time the most difficult
but i was okay no symptoms
it's day 17 now and followed the
protocols because of no symptoms and
also the full follow-up of the protocol
i didn't see the
need for uh testing i can
assure you that i'm i'm okay
and actually very very busy
so the most important thing is following
the protocol thank you
thank you dr tedros i think we are
coming
to the end of this press conference
before i close it formally i would like
to invite dr pedros for his final words
dr pedros the floor is yours
okay thank you thank you fedila
and thank you so much for those who have
joined
today and see you in our upcoming
presser thank you all the best
thank you dr tedros and colleagues for
your participation
and many thanks to journalists who are
regularly uh following our press
uh briefings and special thanks also to
our
interpreters team i remind you that we
will
send you the audiophile and dr pedro's
remarks right
right after the press conference the
full transcript
will be available um as of tomorrow on
the w-2
website if you have any follow-up
question please don't hesitate to
contact the who media team
thank you and have a nice evening
you